اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام لم تهنا منطقه
شرقي المتوسط بوقت طويل للهدوء فقد عادت
ازمتها الى التوتر مجددا تركيا تستانف
اعمال التنقيب واليونان تعتبر ذلك خطوه
استفزازيه تصعيديه وتلوح بعقوبات تحت غطاء
اوروبي ضد الاتراك تطورات عصفت ببقه امل
لخفض التوتر بين البلدين لا حتى من بين
ثنايا لقاء حدر جمع وزيري خارجيته ما
تبادل فيه الطرفان خطاب حسن نيات لم تصمد
هشاشته امام نقاط احتكاك ساخنه بين انقره
وعدد من العواصم تتق قدمها اثنا ودعمتها
باريس المزيد في تقرير امال
وناس عو على بدء ازمه شرق المتوسط بين
تركيا واليونان تعود بكامل جوانبها سفينه
المسح التركيه اورتش رايس اولا تبدا مهمه
جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في سياق ما
تؤكد تركيا انه حق من حقوقها البحريه
تمارسه في مناطق نفوذها شرقي المتوسط وبحر
ايجا والرفض اليوناني المتصاعده لهجته
ثانيا لما تعتبره اليونان انتهاكا تركيا
لمناطق تقع ضمن نطاق سيادتها وتهديدا
للسلام والامن في
المنطقه ومع ذلك لا شيء كان يؤشر الى هذه
العوده السريعه للتوتر على العكس توالت
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه اشارات تهدئه لعل
اهمها هذا اللقاء الذي جمع وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود شاوش اوجلو بنظيره اليوناني
نيكوس ديندياس في براتيسلافا بسلوفاكيا
قراه مراقبون عده على انه انخراط فعلي
للبلدين على طريق التفاوض لحل ازمه شرق
المتوسط وقد تزامن مع اشاده رئيس الوزراء
اليوناني بما قال انها تحركات تركيه
لتهدئه التوترات الاخيره وقبلها اعلن
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلس يان
ستولتنبرغ وضع اليه تجنب الاشتباكات
العرضيه في شرق البحر المتوسط مشددا على
انها ستوفر ساحه ملائمه للجهود
الدبلوماسيه بين عضوي حلف شمال الاطلسي
فلماذا لم تصمد كل هذه المؤشرات هل هي
تعقيدات العلاقه بين تركيا واثينا
المزدحمه بالخلافات بدءا بالحدود البحريه
ووصولا الى الملف القبرصي ام هو الاستفا
الاقليمي على خلفيه الصراع على موارد
الطاقه الشرقي المتوسط وفي ساحات اخرى
ساخنه على غرار كارباخ مما قد يؤجج فتيل
الازمه ويحول دون تقديم طرفي النزاع ما
يلزم من تنازلات تعلم انقره واثينا يقينا
ان هذا التصعيد الاخيره قد يؤدي الى
الاسوا فقد كان البلدان قاب قوسين من
اختباره خلال الشهرين الماضيين في مياه
المتوسط مع بدء المرحله الاولى من مهمه
سفينه المسح التركيه عمدت اليونان حينها
الى تنظيم مناورات بحريه ردت عليها تركيا
بمناورات مضاده وذلك على وقع اتهامات
وتصعيد كلامي لم يقتصر على تركيا واليونان
بل انخرطت فيه مصر وفرنسا والاتحاد
الاوروبي قبل ان تعود السفينه الى السواحل
التركيه يوم الث عش من سبتمبر الماضي
يومها اكدت انقر انها لن تتنازل عن حقوقها
في هذه المنطقه من شرق المتوسط
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول جوركان زنجين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن اثينا البروفيسور بيوتس سا
كوناس استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
اثينا ارحب بكما وابدا معك بروفيسور تسا
كوناس مهمه السفينه التركيه كانت مبرمجه
من قبل فهل يستدعي ذلك كل هذا الغضب
اليوناني في
اعتقادك
ان تعتبر ما يحدث في شرق المتوسط
والقرارات التركيه المتعلقه بهذا بهذه
النشاطات
في اعاده او استئناف العمليه والتي تم
التوافق عليها فيما يتعلق بمحا حثات
التنقيب والتي كانت
ستبدا في وقت قريب الان لذلك اعتبرت اثنا
ان هذا الامر يخل بهذه الامر وكان هنالك
ايضا مبادر تان تم تقديمها من قبل تركيا
ادت الى هذا
الغضب اليوناني كان هنالك في ميناء ما
يتعلق
بفتح
بروش في القبرص والذي تم ادانته من قبل
مجلس الامن والامر الثاني يتعلق باعاده
ارسال الصوت لا يصل بوضوح حول مناطق
متنازع في المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه سيد
جوركان زنجين ضيفنا من اسطنبول هل كانت
مثل هذه الخطوه ضروريه من وجهه نظر تركيا
خاصه وسط تطلع اقليمي ودولي ايضا لخفض
التوتر في اعقاب اللقاء الذي جمع وزيري
خارجيه اثنا وانقره يعني
مؤخرا في حقيقه الامر دعوني اوضحوا امرا
ال كان
هنالك
كان هنالك قرار من اليونان تم اطلاقه بعد
كان هنالك فيما يتعلق بالعقوبات كان
بعد قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي وقد قامت ايضا
كان هنالك اتفاق لعدم اي خرق لاي القرارات
لذلك و لذلك بالنسبه للقرارات الاستفزازيه
قررت انقره ان ترسل السفينه مره اخرى الى
شرق المتوسط اليونان ايضا كانت تهدف
منذ قمه الاتحاد الاوربي السابقه ان تحصل
على قرار بفرض عقوبات على تركيا ولم تحصل
على هذا القرار لذلك هي تحاول الان ان
تقوم بعمليات استفزازيه من اجل الحصول على
عقوبات على تركيا من القمه القادمه في ال
21 من ديسمبر لذلك كان هذا السبب وهذا هو
الامور التي ادت الى كل الى زياده التواتر
من الجانب التركي انقره تعتبر هذه القضيه
على انها ربما امور متعلقه بالمناطق
الاقتصاديه وتتعلق بانها تعتبرها امور
سياديه لذلك يجب بامكان مناقشه هذه الامور
مع كل الدول التي لديها سواحل في المنطقه
دعونا نتحدث ونناقش هذه المنطقه حتى
الحدود البحريه بامكاننا ان نناقشها سويه
لكن لسوء
الحظ لم لم يكون هك اي قرار في من الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القمه التي او اي ترحيب او
تحرك ايجابي من اثنا لذلك
انقره قالت انني لن امتنع ولن اوقف هذه
الفعاليات ولن اتنازل عن حقوقي في المناطق
الاقتصاديه اذا ما كنتم راغبين بالنقاش
والتحدث انا مستعده لكن اذا لم ترغبوا
بذلك ليس هنالك امامي اي حل اخر اشرت سيد
زنكين الى العقوبات وهنا اتوجه اليك
بروفيسور س كوناس عن هذه العقوبات التي
لوحت بها اثينا عقوبات اوروبيه ان لم ت
تراجع انقره عن موقفها هل هو مجرد تلويح
ام ان هناك فعلا هناك ورقه جاهزه بالتزكيه
داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي لم يكن هنالك اي نيه مسبقه من
اليونان في مساله قياده الامر الخاص
بالعقوبات العقوبات هي فقط رساله يتم
ارسالها الى طرف لا يحترم القانون الدولي
هذا هذه كانت رساله واضحه في قمه الاتحاد
الاوروبي انه في حاله ان تركيا لا تستجيب
للقانون الدولي والاتفاقات الدوليه قد
يكون هنالك عقوبات مع ذلك في نفس الوقت
كان هنالك اتفاق بين اليونان وتركيا الذي
تم ضمانه من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
الاتحاد المحادثات الخاصه بالتنقيب يجب ان
تبدا في اقرب وقت ممكن اعتقد انه بالرغم
من ان هذا الاتفاق تم عقده وابرام بين
الدولتين لكن
تركيا قامت بتخريب العمليه في مرحله ما عن
طريق اطلاق
مبادرات لا تعني انها ستكون نافعه
لمبادره او
سير قدما في العمليه لذلك هذا هو السبب
الاساسي الذي ادى الى نوع
من وايضا القاء المسؤوليه على تركيا وذا
لا يعني ان الام انها جاده في ابرام
الاتفاقات وايضا الرساله من جانب اليونان
واضحه نحن هنا من اجل مستعدون لاجراء اي
محادثات خاصه بالتنقيب
تعتمد
على تفاهم
معينه فيما يتعلق بالمناطق الاقتصاديه
المحدده هذا ما قاله الاتحاد
الاوروبي الاستناد
على القوانين
الخاصه بالخطوط البحريه التي هي اليونان
والاتحاد الاوروبي جزء منها لكن تركيا
ليست جزء كذلك ما يهم الان ان يكون هنالك
اجراء للمحادثات التنقيب الصه بالنقيب ان
تبدا باقرب وقت ممكن وهذه نقطه مهمه للغ
سيد زنجين الى اي مدى يمكن فصل هذا التوتر
عن نقاط بل عن خطوط احتكاك ساخنه لانقره
في ملفات اخرى مع خصومها اذا ما تحدثنا عن
كارباخ ليبيا وساحات اخرى
مثلا كما تع
هنالك
قضايا اخرى لكن عندما نتحدث عن هذا الملف
ملف شرق المتوسط الامور واضحه هنالك طريقه
للوصول الى حل حتى في قمه الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولاعلان النهائي كان واضحا وكان
يدعو الى اجراء مؤتمر دولي وقبلت انقر هذا
الامر قالت انقره لنجلس سويه ونصل الى حل
سويه كل
الدول تتقد ع دول لديها سواحل في منطقه
الشرق المتوسط لذلك عليهم ان يجلسوا مع
بعضهم البعض وايضا يحددوا ويي رسم الحدود
البحريه في شرق المتوسط من له ماذا وين خط
الساحلي لمصر وخاص
باليونان لذلك انقره ليس لديها اي شيء ما
تخشاه لان تركيا هي تتمتع باطول ساحل في
منطقه المتوسط لذلك ام حتى لو ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان مخلصا وصادقا في ايجاد حل
لهذه الازمه في شرق المتوسط يجب ان يدفع
بهذه القضيه
ويج اقليميا من اجل الوصول الى حل حتى
اليوم قبل ساعتين قال الرئيس اجرى الرئيس
اردوغان مع مسؤولين كبار اوروبيين وقال
لهم لماذا لا تتخذوا اي خطوات واضحه في
تنظيم هذه هذا المؤتمر الاقليمي لذلك
اعتقد ان هذه هي الخطوه الاهم في طريق
ايجاد حل لهذه الازمه اذا اذا ما سميناها
ازمه ننتقل الى البروفيسور تسكوس اتهمت
تركيا بعدم الوفاء بتعهدات والتزامات اقرت
امام او خلال لقاء وزيري خارجيه البلدين
ما هي هذه الالتزامات التي لم تقم بها
تركيا وماذا عن طرفكم
ايضا
قلت انه كان هنالك التزامات تعهد بها
الطرفان وليس فقط وزراء الخارجيه لكن
رؤساء وزراء البلدان والتي اعتقدوا انني
اكرر تعتمد مره اخرى على القانون
الدولي القرار الذي
اتخذه المجلس في المجلس الاوروبي في الاول
من اكتوبر كان واضحا انه حتى في المؤتمر
الثنائي و سيحصل على شرط ان
تركيا
توقف سلوكياتها ونشاطاتها غير القانونيه
لذلك القواعد واضحه والقوانين واضحه انه
لكلا الطرفين عليهما ان يلتزما بهذه
التعهدات سيد زنجين من اللافت ايضا ان
الخطاب التركي جاء هذه المره على لسان
وزير الدفاع خلوصي اكار تحديدا امام كليه
حربيه متحدثا فيها عن مصالح تركيا
الاستراتيجيه السؤال لماذا وزير الدفاع
وليس غيره من المسؤولين
الاتراك عندما يتعلق الامر بالقانون
الدولي كما يشير له ضيفك من اثينا دعونا
دعوني اعطيك
مثلا جزيره الصغرى القضيه الاساسيه جزيره
صغيره تسمى كوستا ديز هي
تبعد كيلومترين من الساحل التركي اليونان
وهي القضيه كلها تاتي من هذه الامر
باعتماد على هذه الجزيره الصغيره التي هي
ضمن الحدود السياديه لتركيا تقول اليونان
ان هذه
منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه هذا الامر ضد القانون
الدولي عنذ عندما يتحدث حول القانون
الدولي بالاعتماد على هذه الجزيره ليس
هنالك اي
حق لذلك هذه قضيه اساسيه كل المشاكل بدات
من هناك عندما يتعلق الامر بقرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي وال البيان النهائي هم لم
يتحدثوا عن هذه القضايا القانونيه يتحدثوا
عن الازمه السياسيه لكن ما هي ما هو اساس
هذه الازمه ما هو الوضع القانوني دعونا
لماذا لا نتحدث تركيا لم
تزعم هذه الحقوق بين ليله وضحاها كان
هنالك معايير واضحه ا حدود من لماذا نتحدث
حول هذه القضايا انقره تضغط دعونا نتحدث
ونجلس ربما اكون انا مخطئا لكن انقره تقول
ربما انا مخطئ لكن دعونا نتحدث مع خبراء
في الولايه القضائيه وخبراء قانوني ونرسم
الحدود لكن لم يتحدثوا عن هذه القضيه ابدا
قالوا فقط لا تدخلوا الى تلك المياه لا
تذهبوا الك لا تبداوا لا ترسلوا سفنك
الخاصه بالتنقيب هناك لكن ما مياه من هناك
دعونا نحدد ونقرر حول هذه القضيه لذلك
عندما يتعلق بمصلحه تركيا نعم بالتاكيد
انقره تقول ان هذه حقوق سياديه وهذه مصالح
الاستراتيجيه هنا
لانني انا البلد هو ربما لدي استهلاك اكبر
للغاز الطبيعي والنفط ونعرف جيدا ان هنالك
في المتوسط وهنالك
مخزون كبير لامكانيات خاصه بالغاز اسرائيل
وجدت ذلك هذه استفادت منها ومصر ايضا
وايضا تركيا لديها استهلاك كبير هي
المستهلك الاكبر للغاز الطبيعي تريد ايضا
ان تبحث في
نفس المكان وهي تتمتع باطول ساحلي لذلك
بالتاكيد يجب ان يكون لديه الحق في
التنقيب اذا ما كانت الحدود تمثل مشكله او
متنازع عليه دعونا نجلس ونتحدث ط بروفيسور
تيكوس هل هناك في رايك اطراف لها مصلحه في
دفع الامور نحو الخلاف والى نقطه ال عوده
او الى الصدام
مثلا ارغب ان ا كد على نقطتين انا اوافق
تماما مع زميلي على انه عندما تكون هنالك
مطالب مختلفه للدول قد تكون متداخله يجب
عليهم ان يجلسوا ويتحدثوا لكن عليهم ان
يهيئوا الاسس لمثل هذه المحادثات من اجل
تهيئه الاسس لمثل
هذه المحادثات او المفاوضات لا يجب عليهم
ان يتبعوا سياسات هي غير قانونيه او
مستفزه وما هو غير قانون
حول طريق تركيا وسلوكها هو انها
قررت بشكل احادي ان تقوم بارسال سفينه
تنقيب
يصاحبها سفن حربيه في مناطق قال عنها
زميلي بشكل صحيح انها مناطق متنازع عليها
من قبل اليونان وتركيا هذه هي المشكله
المتعلقه بسلوك تركيا يجب ان يكون هنالك ك
تخلي كاممل عن هذه السلوكيات من اجل ان
يكون هنالك ظروف مواتيه لاجراء حوار يجب
ان يكون هنالك نيه طيبه من قبل البلدان
ليجلسا على طاوله المفاوضات وكيفيه تحديد
المناطق الاقتصاديه وايضا اذا لم يكن
هنالك حل بامكاننا ان نحول الامر الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه من اجل تحديد هذه
المناطق سيد زنكين الاتحاد الاوربي ق ق
انه سيعاقب تركيا اذا عادت للتنقيب شرقي
المتوسط ماذا تتوقعون في هذا السياق وما
هو المتوقع من رد من قبل
انقره عندما يتعلق الامر بالعقوبات
الاقتصاديه او عندما يتعلق بالعقوبات كما
اسميها بين هلالين حول السياسات الحاليه
لن يعمل لن ينجح هذا الامر لذلك انقره
قالت دعونا نتحدث حول الوضع القانون
ساعطيك حقيقه ان
طول الجزر اليونانيه المطل على شرق
المتوسط هي
61 كيل متر 160
كر هنالك ثلاث او اربع جزر هي مطله على
شرق المتوسط هي
16 67 ر لكن تركيا
1700 ر هذا هو الوضع القانوني لذلك
اليونان لا تريد ان تتحدث عن حول هذه
القضيه
وتريد ان تستدعي اصدقائها في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وان تحظى بدعمهم وتدفع تركيا نحو
الزاويه هل هذه هي الطريقه لايجاد حل
انقره تعتبر كما قلت في بدايه انقره ت
تعتبر هذه القضيه كقضيه سياديه لذلك الامر
لا يصدق
الامر لا لا يصدق ان يكون هنالك تنازلات
بامكاننا ان نتحدث بامكاننا ان نعيد
ترسيمه الحدود ونحدد الحدود البحريه مع
باشراك متخصصين دوليين هذا ليس هنالك اي
مشكله لكن لا يمكنكم ان تخبروا تركيا لا
تذهبوا هناك لا يمكنكم ان تناقشوا هذه
القضيه ان طول ساح لكم غير مهم في شرق
الموصلط واذا ما قمتم بذلك سنعاقب الامر
لا يسير بهذا بهذه الطريقه لم ينجح في
السابق ولا اعتقد انه سينجح ابدا الرسائل
التي تاتي من انقره تظهر هذا الامر
دات ربما صراع بالتاكيد لكن بامكان اي شيء
ان يحدث لسوء الحظ ما لم
يتم مناقشه هذه القضيه على هذه الاسس شكرا
لك من اسطنبول جوركان زنجين الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من اثنا
البروفيسور فوس تكونا استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه
اثنا بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد
شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]